الاحتجاجات في ايران وان خف زخمها في
الشوارع لكن الاحتقان الشعبي لا يزال
موجودا تقارير اعلاميه حقوقيه كشفت ان
السلطات الايرانيه اعتقلت ما لا يقل عن
185 شخصا خلال شهر يناير الماضي في
بروجستان ايران رجح ناشطون حقوقيون ان
يكون المعتقلون حديثا في مدينه زاهدان
اعلى من 185 بسبب الاجواء الامنيه الشديده
وحملات الاعتقال واسعه النطاق اضافه الى
انقطاع الانترنت في سياق متصل افاد موقع
هانجا والحقوقي عن اعتقال ما لا يقل عن
182 مواطنا كرديا خلال الشهر الماضي في
مختلف المدن الكرديه في ايران في موازاه
ذلك اظهر مقطع فيديو استمرار الاحتجاجات
في اصفهان حيث ردد الاهالي شعار وراء كل
قتيل الف شخص وذلك ضمن الاحتجاجات ضمنا ضد
النظام
[موسيقى]